Alright, so what I'd like to do is work up
to a proof that K-means does something good. [LAUGH] And to
do that I think it's helpful to have little bit more
precise notation than what I was doing before. So here we
go, let's, we're going to work up to doing K-means in
a Euclidean space. And the notation that I'm going to use is,
we've got at any given moment in time in the algorithm,
there's some partition, p super t of x. And these clusters
are defined the same way that we did before, which
it just returns the, you know, some kind of identifier
for cluster x is in and this is at iteration
t of K-means. We also have another kind of more convenient
way of writing that which is C sub i of
t, which is the set of all points in cluster
i. It's really just the same as the set x,
such that p of x equals i. Does that make sense?
>> Yeah, okay that makes perfect sense.
You've got some kind of partition, and everything in the
same partition belongs together in something you're calling C for cluster.
>> Good, and we're also going to need to be able to refer to the
center of a cluster because we're in
a Euclidean space, it's meaningful to add the
objects together. So, take all the objects
that are in some cluster, Ci at iteration
t and divide by the number of objects in that cluster. So just summing those
points together. This is also sometimes called the centroid, right?
>> Right, so it's the mean or the centroid.
>> Yeah it's like. That's right. I mean in one dimension it's
definitely the mean. In higher dimensions it's like a per dimension mean.
>> Oh, so in fact you're going to end up with K means.
>> Oh, I see what you did there.
>> Mm.
>> So now, here's an equation arrow version of the algorithm,
that we start off picking centers in some way for iteration zero,
and we hand it over to this process that's going to assign the partitions. In
particular, the partition of point x is going to be the minimum over
all the clusters of the distance between x and the center of that cluster.
Alright, so it's just assigning each point
to its closest center. Does that make sense?
>> Mm-hm, and that all those bars
with the sub two just mean Euclidean distance.
>> Yeah,
we're just, that's right, exactly. We just computing the distance
between those two things. And we hand that partition over
to the process that computes the center. So it's, it's
now using this other representation of the clustering Ci, it's
adding the points together, divided by the number of points
in that cluster, and it hands those centers back to
this first process to recompute the cluster. So we're just
going to be ping-ponging back and forth between these two processes.
>> Okay.
>> Good?
>> Sure, and t keeps getting updated after every cycle.
>> Right, yes. So, this is where t gets incremented, t plus plus. So this is
the algorithm, and an interesting fact about it
is: Do you remember when we talked about optimization?
>> I do remember when we talked about optimization.
>> And optimization is good because it's finding
better and better answers. So if we can think
of this as being kind of an optimization
algorithm then that could be good. It could be
that that what we're doing, what we're going around here
is not just randomly reassigning things, but actually improving things.
>> Okay. Well how are you going to convince me of that?
>> Alright, let's do that.